you  [Music]  hi I'm Anna Kendrick and I'm in New York  shooting for GQ magazine two subjects  never bring up on a first date or  anything to do with the actual reality  of your family and you know liver cancer  how we got the probably got it first  date is a tricky thing because even  though it's meaningless if the guy  doesn't or doesn't offer it suggests  poor judgment more than anything I was  like let me start a Jew and it was bad  and I had to lie about it where my  favorite first date the guy was mad at  me because I had never tried del Taco  so we went to like the dry of crew of  del Taco and it was super cute you can  make del Taco romantic think you've got  a good thing going if sex is off the  table and you're like let's try and get  to know each other I would recommend  drinking highly that was probably not  all good advice but I hope  [Music]  you